this is a Fox News Alert The Associated
Press is reporting and now we're getting
some South Korean reports that North
Korea North Korean leader Kim jong-un
says he will suspend nuclear and
long-range missile tests and shut down a
nuclear test site the South Korean news
agency Yonhap saying that he has
announced that his country will suspend
nuclear and missile tests from April
21st North Korea will stop these tests
and launches of intercontinental
ballistic missiles says the agency the
North will shut down a nuclear test site
in the country's northern side to prove
the vow to suspend nuclear tests the
decision was made at a meeting of the
Central Committee of the Workers Party
the WPK today this is according to
Korean news agency if true significant
major win for the trump administration
as it pushes for the deep nuclearization
of the Hermit Kingdom and obviously sets
up this potential meeting with President
Trump and Kim jong-un
but again North Korea is saying it's
freezing its tests and launches for the
time being